la nouvelle équipe de raymond barre
connus demain le gouvernement répondra
aux exigences de continuité d'ouverture
remous à la base du pc certaines
fédérations conteste la ligne marché
après l'échec des législatives la loi
caillavet sur les dons d'organes la fin
des interdits
hollywood des oscar mérité diane keaton
et charlie puces et simone signoret pour
la vie devant soi
messieurs bonsoir nous allons profiter
du seul jour de répit que nous laisse le
calendrier politique français pour
souffler un peu à la veille de la
formation du gouvernement et pour
aborder un problème tout à fait
passionnant celui des dons d'organes
depuis ce matin depuis la parution d'un
décret au journal officiel
les prélèvements d'organes sont
facilitées en france
le dossier n'est pas d'aujourd'hui la
loi imaginé par le sénateur caillavet a
été publié fin 76 et il a fallu attendre
plus de 15 mois donc pour qu'elles
deviennent aujourd'hui effectif
c'est une wap que l'on peut schématiser
très facilement
si vous ne dites pas non de façon
formelle c'est que vous êtes d'accord
pour que l'on prélève sur votre corps
après décès tel ou tel organe une loi
d'importance qui devrait permettre de
réaliser par exemple les quelques 1000
transplantation rénale nécessaires
chaque année en france alors que 400
seulement sont aujourd'hui effective
dans la pratique
regardez ces exemples de dialyse
autrement dit de rein artificiel
c'est moi qui prépare le matériel et ma
femme un pic pour vous faites aux sept
véhicules ont fait cette piqûre dans le
bras gauche de piqûres
oui pouvez nous montrer
et là vous avez une artère ici est une
vaine ici pour faire un circuit aller
retour du sens ce matériel n'est pas
transportable
là comment faites-vous pour partir en
vacances il faut trouver un soin une
clinique sur un hôpital qui puisse vous
acceptez qui est des places qui est des
malades qu'ils soient partis en congés
ailleurs et qui puisse nous prendre dans
ma période des congés la dialyse c'est
d'un remède contre un autre maladie ça
nous permet de vivre mais la grève c'est
quand ça réussit c'est réellement la
guérison reprendre une vie normale
là vous avez l'impression de vivre de
vivre un demi si j'étais gré c'est
d'abord
j'aurai une entière liberté je serai
libre de faire ce que je veux m'en aller
eux-mêmes à l'étranger si vous voulez je
suis sans avoir sans être obligé de
penser à magali ce qui se passe dans
deux trois jours avoir plus de contacts
avec mes amis gardez les contacts sortir
plus m'évader si vous voulez parce qu'en
dehors du travail de la dialyse à voir
le fait d'avoir un enfant c'était c'est
mon but quoi et est en dialyse je n'ai
aucune chance d'en avoir un si jamais
j'avais un jour la chance d'être
transplanté je pourrais au bout de deux
ou trois ans si maman ma greffe marche
bien avoir un enfant voire eu cette
chance d'avoir un enfant ce qui est très
important je pense sans la vision forme
chaque jour les descentes vivante avec
art artificielle espère chaque jour le
télex de france transplant regroupe sur
une même liste les 2500 personnes déjà
en attente d'une greffe dans toute la
france aujourd'hui l'application de la
loi sur les prélèvements d'organes ouvre
de nouveaux horizons
car avant c'était à la famille du
donneur de décider quand celui ci
n'avait pas lui même précisé ses
intentions et souvent sous le choc du
chagrin les familles commencé par
refuser après il était trop tard ce qui
fait qu'à l'heure actuelle seulement 400
personnes bénéficient d'une
transplantation
dorénavant tous les français adultes
devront décider eux mêmes s'ils refusent
un prélèvement pour les médias tout
devient plus simple c'est toi aussi bien
au travail
une façon très importante en facilitant
les relations entre les médecins et les
familles et en évitant au médecin
d'avoir apposé aux familles des donneurs
potentiels
la question du prélèvement d'organes
dans des circonstances qui sont les plus
pénibles pour la famille c'est à dire
celle où elle vient de perdre un être
cher
finalement pourquoi est il nécessaire de
mettre tous les français à contribution
ses déserts pour deux raisons la
première raison est que l'on a besoin de
savoir quelle est l'opinion des français
sur le traitement de l'insuffisance
rénale chronique par la transplantation
rénale le veulent et ils ne le veulent
t'ils pas s'ils le veulent il faut
qu'ils contribuent et qu'il donne les
organes
la deuxième raison est que pour réussir
une transplantation
raynal il faut la faire dans les
meilleures conditions possibles de
compatibilité tissulaire ans pour cela
il faut avoir un grand choix de donneurs
plus on aura de donneurs plus on pourra
transplanté en compatibilité et
rapidement les malades qui en ont besoin
ouais donc le problème voilà maintenant
la solution telle que l'a imaginé le
législateur à l'initiative d'henri t y
avait une solution qui bien entendu ne
va pas sans créer quelques petites
difficultés être bien clair il ya trois
cas à considérer d'abord vous êtes
vivant et vous voulez donner un organe
s'il s'agit d'un organe non régénéra bhl
comme par exemple à 1
il faut signifier votre autorisation
devant un médecin magistrats par écrit
s'il s'agit d'un organe régénéra bhl
comme greffe de peau par exemple il vous
suffit simplement de donner
l'autorisation aux médecins par écrit
devant témoins
deuxième cas par testament vous voulez
légué votre corps ou une partie de votre
corps à un hôpital bien précis cet
hôpital est donc propriétaire entre
guillemets de votre corps ou de la
partie du corps que vous lui avait légué
et les autres hôpitaux se partagent le
reste
troisièmement donc le prélèvement
automatique alors d'abord pour les
mineurs il faut de toute façon
l'autorisation des parents pour les
adultes la loi donc autorise ce
prélèvement automatique si vous n'êtes
pas d'accord il faut le signifier sur un
registre ouvert l'hôpital et les
registres ont certainement centralisée
pour que tous les médecins de france
puis savoir si vous êtes d'accord ou non
mais vous pouvez également noté ce
désaccord sur une pièce officielle
d'identité comme la carte d'identité ou
le passeport mais vous ne pouvez le
faire à mon sens qu au crayon car
théoriquement il est interdit d' ajouter
quoi que ce soit sur les pièces
officielles
et puis de toute façon vous pouvez
peut-être changer d'avis je pense
personnellement que c'est une très bonne
chose si court et je trouve que
tout le monde devrait donner tout ce
qu'on peut pour était seulement je sais
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
content pour des raisons par exactement
religieux mais enfin pour des raisons il
n'aime pas l'idée que leurs corps se
ferait l'amputer ou utiles et après leur
mort tout dépend de son idée de la mort
je trouve que c'est une atteinte à la
liberté je sais pas vous me prenez tout
à fait de course que j'ai jamais
réfléchi je peux pas vous répondre
comme ça je viens de perdre ma mère je
ne sais mais en même temps ça me fera
sait quelqu'un me disais bon vin on va
retirer les rendre votre mère le premier
dab le premier réflexe est est une
espèce de recul mais à la réflexion je
suis d'accord quoi c'est vrai que c'est
comme ça que se pose le problème alors
martine allard unio il faut dire qu on
rêve toutes sortes d'organes
oui je vous ai dressé un catalogue
rapide vc2 très vite ici que commence
par les yeux les cornées l'arc stimulus
qui nous avait très vite coeur foie rein
intestins organes génitaux homme ou
femme les jo la moelle osseuse le sens
des boues d'artères des articulations de
la peau et j'en passe je crois j'ai re
j'ai compté 25 organe que l'on se réfère
pas le cerveau alors le cerveau alors là
ici inancement d'interrogation on ne
peut pas pour l'instant greffer le
cerveau et avant longtemps mais de toute
façon on se demande toujours si c'est
encore greffer sur un savon ou s avoue
greffer sur un corps alors les problèmes
techniques pour tous à son réseau lui
c'est à dire la chirurgie marche bien
c'est la plomberie c'est tout ce qu'on
voudra
le vrai problème c'est d'éviter le rejet
comme vous savez là nous ne sommes pas
maîtres du jeu mais vraiment pas du jeu
nous faisons ce que nous pouvons et
c'est pourquoi si tout ceci a été essayé
c'est surtout des rencontres par lens
alors vous reste on en parle toujours
oui alors uniquement alors de façon
générale on essayait de graisser que des
organes vitaux autant qu'on n'a pas
maîtrisé le rejet d'un organe puisque le
roger s'il n'y a pas de remplacement
c'est la mort alors vous avez 2 1
bon mais vous avez surtout lorsqu'ils
ont disparu vous ne pouvez plus vivre
mais vous avez le recours aux reins
artificiels que vous avez vu la dialyse
mais si le rejet de la greffe a eu lieu
vous pouvez retourner au rein artificiel
ce qu'ils nous disent ce qui n'existe
pas pour les eaux alors encore un mot de
la qualité médicale pour vous dire que
john wayne a subi une opération à coeur
ouvert pour remplacer une valve de
l'aorte
l'acteur mais qu'un va bien dit ses
médecins john wayne à soixante dix ans
et nous n'arrivons à la politique trois
chapitres ce soir les consultations de
raymond barre qui prépare son équipe une
équipe dont il annoncera la composition
damas soir les problèmes internes au
parti communiste
et puis d'abord les suite de l'élection
de jacques chaban delmas à la présidence
de l'assemblée nationale une élection
que vous avez pu vivre
hier soir en direct dans le journal les
titres de nos confrères sont partagés
entre la revanche du maire de bordeaux
et l'échec de jacques chirac jacques
chirac qui a convoqué demain soir le
comité central de son parti en séance
extraordinaire
on dit qu'il s'agit de ressouder le rpr
autour de son chef à un moment contestée
hier la sphère du perchoir entre
guillemets et diversement analysé au
sein du rpr simple péripétie fâcheuses
pour michel debré affaire sérieuse
pour yves guéna et pour autant les
relations du rpr et de l'udf ne sont pas
directement affecté aujourd'hui les
présidents des deux groupes
parlementaires claude labbé et roger
chinaud se sont rencontrés pour proposer
à leurs collègues socialistes et
communistes des responsabilités accrues
au sein des commissions l'assemblée et
il apparaît que le président du groupe
communiste souhaite une proportionnelle
intégrale alors que le président du
groupe socialiste s'est montré plus
nuancé et à l'heure actuelle ce soir
nous devons revoir demain
gaston defferre étant donné que du côté
du groupe communiste il y a la volonté
que nous comprenons d'ailleurs fort bien
d'obtenir une proportionnelle intégrale
des commissions y compris les présidents
cela veut dire de commission que nous
n'avons pas la possibilité d'accepter
parce qu'il est
on cerne je peux sur la contagion
éventuelle de répartition des
présidences de commissions entre les nos
deux groupes envisagée
de proposer à l'opposition une
présidence de commission et ça sans
logement pad et si on nous répond le
tout ou rien ce qui est un début de
proposition vient nous le constaterons
constateront très simplement sereinement
et certainement le groupe a considéré
que les propositions des fêtes étaient
insuffisantes a constaté qu'ils
n'offrent que ces propositions ne
répondaient pas à l'application du
principe de la représentation
proportionnelle auxquels nous sommes
attachés que si ce principe avait été
respectée en ce qui concerne les
présidences de commission cela aurait dû
signifier que deux présidences rush
progrès on réduit tout mais de proposer
à nos positions le bouche le relais
sinon et claude labbé reverrons demain
gaston defferre à ce sujet quant aux
communistes déclare tout net refuser
tout strapontin seule une présidence de
commission les intéressent
la lecture du journal officiel qui est
décidément notre bible ce soir nous a
appris ce matin que raymond barre et est
officiellement devenu premier ministre
il a donc remis son mandat de député du
rhône entre lehmann son suppliant le
docteur barry dont et a tout de suite
commencé ses consultations pour la
formation de son 3ème cabinet mais
monsieur bart est un homme discret il
aime bien travailler au téléphone et
c'est la raison pour laquelle noël copte
vous n'avez pas vu grand monde cet après
midi la cour de matignon
eh bien oui patrick le journée était
très calme ici dans la cour de l'hôtel
matignon ce matin le premier ministre
s'est rendu à l'elysée où s'est
entretenu avec le président de la
république et cet après midi il n'a reçu
que deux visites politiques celle de
monsieur rené monory est celle de
monsieur robert boulin on peut penser
que le reste du temps il a consacré en
grande partie à des conversations
téléphoniques savoir d'ores et déjà
qu'elle sera l'orientation un petit peu
de ce nouveau gouvernement
désolé je crois que trois mots résument
des préoccupations du président de la
république et du premier ministre dans
la formation de ce gouvernement ce sont
les mots de continuité d'efficacité et
d'ouverture la continuité
le porte parole de l'elysée nous disait
ce matin l'action politique exige la
durée alors on peut penser qu'un certain
nombre de ministres importants ayant des
postes clés vont conserver ces postes
pour la poursuite de la politique déjà
mené par monsieur raymond barre d
identité
alors vous voulez des noms volonté non
et je précise tout de suite qu'il faut
les employer au conditionnel et qu'ils
relèvent plus de la rumeur que
d'informations officielles ni même
officieuses aller alors on resterait au
gouvernement
messieurs persite bonnet monory
méhaignerie et monsieur jean françois
deniau qui pourrait même avoir une
promotion et devenir ministre des
affaires étrangères là vous parlez des
ministres par les soldats d'état oui
parce que les secrétaires d'état nous ne
sommes pas encore sûrs qu ils figureront
dans la liste des nominations de demain
soir il est possible que ces nominations
interviennent un peu plus tard je
précise également jeu pour le bar
oublier que madame simone veil et
resterai ministre et des règles sans
doute et tendre un peu ces compétences
parmi les autres ministres secrétaires
d'état resterait messieurs stirn 12,2
peu claires et mesdames me sauve
scrivener et pelletier alors maintenant
les promus alors les premiers je vous
disais il y aurait donc essentiellement
pour l'instant tout cas parce que tonio
qui deviendra ministre des affaires
étrangères madame simone veil qui aurait
sans doute et des compétences étendues
et puis alors les nouveaux parmi les
nouveaux on parle de personnalités non
politiques est tel que le sien andré
giraud qui est le patron du commissariat
à l'énergie atomique et un industriel
monsieur georges dechavanne le pdg de
leroy somer
on a parlé également ces jours ci mais
ça n'est pas encore sûr de nouveaux élus
madame louise moreau qui a été récemment
élu à cannes et monsieur bertrand de
maigret
le gendre de monsieur poniatowski qui a
été élu dans la sarthe
et il ya les anciens et qui
redeviendrait ministres des anciens qui
ont été ministres à des périodes
d'ailleurs assez différentes
messieurs le cas stasi soissons sudreau
et du raf
or voilà donc pour les rumeurs et par
twitter nous ne parlons pas de ceux qui
partent
s'il faut une conclusion d'un copain
rapidement peu de changements
spectaculaires alors oui
on a l'impression que le premier
ministre et le président de la
république que n'ont pas voulu donner
dans le spectaculaire et le sensationnel
et au nom donc de cette ouverture et de
cette efficacité ils ont surtout cherché
à composer un gouvernement qui par les
personnes et fort son organisation
puisse répondre aux grandes directives
que le président de la république avait
tonné tout récemment encore au premier
ministre quel premier ministre a rappelé
le soir même de sa nomination
la poursuite de l'effort économique de
redressement économique une politique
sociale de plus grande justice sociale
et puis tout le problème des rapports
entre les citoyens et la demie face mais
ajoutons à cela que le prénom un public
qui a reçu ce matin son premier ministre
lui a demandé de réformer les cabinets
ministériels pour qu'il y ait moins
d'écrans entre les ministres et de
l'administration
et de toute façon réponses à toutes ces
questions demain soir peu avant l'heure
du journal après une nouvelle rencontre
giscard barre alors une fois l'équipe
constituée dans quelle direction va s
engager
nous avons de sérieuses éléments de
réponse en relisant le programme des
doigts 10 7 janvier 1978 à blois
la foule des grands jours tous les
ministres sont présents autour de
raymond barre
le premier ministre d'alors ouvre
officiellement la campagne électorale en
présentant son programme
les objectifs que le premier ministre
d'aujourd'hui entend bien respecter et
dont l'application s'échelonnera sur les
cinq années de la présente législature
pour l'emploi pendant deux ans les
petites entreprises et les artisans
bénéficieront d'une exonération de 50 %
des cotisations sociales pour le
personnel jeunes qu'ils n'embaucheront
pour les emplois pénibles
la durée légale du travail sera abaissé
de 40 à 38 heures par semaine pour les
salaires la gauche proposaient pour mars
le smic à 2400 francs le premier
ministre n'y pense que pour 1982 une
précision pour réduire les inégalités
les plus basses rémunérations
progresseront plus vite que la moyenne
des salaires malgré les difficultés
économiques l'objectif du gouvernement
sera de sauvegarder le pouvoir d'achat
global des français pour les fans
la progression du pouvoir d'achat des
allocations familiales sera d'au moins
un an et demi pour cent par an le
montant de l'ensemble des prestations
familiales sera revalorisé pour
atteindre des buts 79 un revenu minimum
de 3500 francs par mois pour une famille
de trois enfants quelle que soit la
situation des parents pour les femmes le
travail à temps partiel qui peut offrir
aux femmes d facilité d'emploi sera
développée l'état donnera l'exemple en
offrant dix mille emplois partiels
chaque année pendant cinq ans la durée
du congé maternité sera augmentée de
trois mois les personnes âgées les
allocations versées aux personnes les
plus défavorisées
actuellement de 30 francs par jour
seront portés à 40 francs en 1979 soit
près de 3 millions de centimes par an
pour un ménage les personnes âgées
titulaires du minimum vieillesse
bénéficieront de la gratuité des soins
médicaux
toutes ces mesures représentent une
dépense globale de 22 milliards de
francs jusqu'en 1982 même si le problème
du financement de ce programme n'est pas
encore totalement résolue
le premier ministre s'en tient à ses
promesses et à ses seules promesses
la philosophie de blois est toujours
valable quatre mois après nous
choisissons la réforme non le
bouleversement
nous choisissons l'évolution non la
révolution la consolidation du
redressement que nous avons entrepris
impose en effet de ne pas faire
supporter à l'économie française
au moins pendant les deux prochaines
années des charges trop lourd les
mesures à mettre en oeuvre ont été je
vous le garantis soigneusement chiffrés
et elles ont été choisies de telle sorte
que si elles sont convenablement
répartis sur les cinq années à venir
ir leur coûte pourra être supporter sans
dommage par l'économie française
ce à quoi il faut ajouter le fait que
les impôts seront stabilisées pendant
deux ans donc tout cela dans le
programme de bois troisième dossier
politique de la journée les remous au
sein du parti communiste plusieurs fois
nous avons fait état de quelques signes
persistants georges marchais lui-même
avait abordé le problème il hier en
expliquant que c'est vrai une discussion
tout à fait normal était en train de se
dérouler à l'intérieur de son parti mais
que la direction s'en féliciter telle
n'est pas l'opinion de nombreux
observateurs et même de certains
militants nous avons pu interroger si
gérard molina ancien secrétaire général
de l'union des étudiants communistes et
récente auteur d'un livre qui dit bien
ce qu'il veut dire dialogue au pluriel à
l'intérieur du parti comme les suivants
molina qui fait même état d'un certain
désarroi au sein du pc à la suite de la
défaite de la gauche qui parle même des
chèques d'une stratégie et qu'il reste
quelques critiques à la direction de son
parti
le débat a lieu parce qu'il ya eu échec
de la gauche les camarades les militants
communistes disent oui nous avons eu
raison de mettre en garde les français
les travailleurs devant le danger social
démocrate devant le réformisme qui
pointait qui risquait d'être une gestion
de la crise par un gouvernement de
gauche
mais les camarades disent aussi que
cette politique de mise en garde ne
s'est pas accompagné d'une véritable
conception l'union de la gauche un
véritable débat démocratique à la base
avec les masses qui concerne tous les
travailleurs et qui engage non pas
simplement des polémiques d'état major
mais une véritable union large qui
impose élargissent l'union du peuple de
france
en cela vous critiquer l'attitude des
dirigeants communistes qui notamment 10
on rejette toute responsabilité du parti
communiste dans l'échec de ces élections
je crois que la responsabilité
essentielle porte sur le parti
socialiste effectivement mais qu'il y a
des responsabilités secondaire du parti
communiste sa direction de l'incapacité
que nous avons eues à impulser une ligne
de masse autour de l'union de la gauche
je veux dire ici que le débat n'est pas
entre ceux qui refusent le 22e congrès
ce qu'il accepte accepte c'est beaucoup
plus profond que ça c'est un débat et
qui porte sur
l'union du peuple de france et le
contenu clair positif de ce mot d'ordre
je veux dire en exemple que alors que le
22e congrès avaient placé au centre de
son débat l'union du peuple de france
comme mot d'ordre personnes dans la
campagne électorale en a fait état
depuis six mois la direction du parti
n'en parle pas c'est donc ici la
direction du parti qui va à l'encontre
du 22e congrès et de cette conception
dynamique de l'union telle qu'elle
devrait se faire jour aujourd'hui c'est
vrai on a l'impression que les discours
de georges marchais notamment dans ses
meetings s'adressait plutôt aux ouvriers
étaient finalement très populiste c'est
ça que vous lui reprochez un petit peu
non la campagne sur des bases ouvrière a
été juste
mais il fallait avec cette campagne sur
des bases ouvrière aussi considérer les
employés les cadres les intellectuels
faire donc d'un autre mot d'ordre une
réalité concrète de tous les jours ce
qui n'a pas été le cas je veux dire
aussi que c'est un débat qui engagent
des problèmes plus larges de fond qui
applique notre stratégie ce sont donc
des problèmes qui ne verront pas leur
solution dans les jours les semaines qui
viennent ça engage le parti dans son
ensemble
c'est un des problèmes très sérieux cela
demande donc à être examiné dans le
cadre plus large de la préparation d'un
congrès et nous croyons que ces
problèmes là ne peuvent pas trouver leur
solution dans les réunions des
commissions d'experts mais par
l'ensemble du parti par l'ensemble de
tous les communistes à la base alors
actuellement vous même vous êtes
communiste
quelles formes peuvent prendre ces
discussions savait quels sont vos
possibilités de discuter entre vous et
de discuter avec vos dirigeants
est-ce qu'il y en a c'est évidemment
dans les cellules que semaines le débat
est là il semaine démocratiquement comme
je l'expliquais tout à l'heure il
semaine très largement il doit continuer
dans toute la france je le crois ça se
déroule comme ça là où les endroits que
nous connaissons il serait bon que la
presse du parti l'humanité notamment se
fasse plus largement l'écho des
positions diverses que les camarades
formule dans les cellules non pas les
contestations globale qui arrivent par
lettre on peut les publier mais beaucoup
plus profondément il plus sérieusement
les questions politiques de fond que se
posent les camarades
alors disons le tout net jean françois
kahn ya des problèmes à l'intérieur de
chaque bloc pratiquement depuis le
lendemain du natives merle absolument
alors ce qui est intéressant dans les
cas difficiles c'est que d'habitude et
comme mm pas tellement qu'on parle de
leurs problèmes et n'en parle jamais à
l'extérieur car ils considèrent un peu
ça comme une agression quand on en parle
ce moment là c'est georges marchais
lui-même qui a reconnu qu avait eu une
véritable effervescence au sein du parti
communiste a récemment lui il a parlé de
30 personnes qui avait écrit deux ou
trois cellules qui avait envoyé des
pétitions il ya plusieurs dizaines de
personnes qui ont écrit qu'ils ont rendu
leur mécontentement public s'est déjà
nouveau mais enfin les ya près de six
cent mille militants communistes il ya
près de trente mille cellules
ce sont des gens qui ne sont pas
clandestins qui ne se cache pas je veux
dire par là que nos journalistes vous
moi nous en rencontrons des militants
communistes et notre métier c'est notre
travail et donc nous pouvons dire que
depuis plusieurs semaines nous
rencontrons des militants des
responsables communistes qui témoignent
qu'il ya une grande interrogation est un
grand très grand malaise droit dans le
parti nous avons même aujourd'hui
téléphoner dans plusieurs fédérations de
france dans le nord et le sud de la
france d'avant téléphoné à des
responsables communistes que nous
connaissons et tous nous ont confirmé qu
il y actuellement un vaste et très
profond débat et ce qui est nouveau
voyez vous c'est très souvent par
exemple en 56 il y en a peut-être qu'il
peut y avoir certains mécontentements au
niveau des cellules à des bons au niveau
des cellules mais s'est amoindrie au
niveau des sections c'est ça le
centralisme démocratique vous savez puis
au niveau des fédérations alors ça
devient encore plus feutrée là d'après
ce que nous ont dit ces gens et bien le
débat a lieu non seulement dans les
cellules mais au niveau des sections et
au niveau des fédérations
c'est à dire mais au niveau des
responsables de l'appareil c'est ça qui
est nouveau et c'est ce qui fait que ce
qui se passe actuellement à l'intérieur
du pc est plus important que ce qui
s'est passé en 56 ou en 61 effectivement
bien a prévu après budapest
soixante et un bon c'était quand
servins casanova sont fait exclure bien
et où ça ne concerne effectivement des
étudiants des intellectuels ou alors
quelques fédérations particulière la
l'effervescence est plus grande mais
georges marchais a dit qu'il n'y aurait
pas d'exclu cette fois ci alors ça c'est
nouveau il y aura pas de d'ailleurs on
n'exclut plus depuis quelques temps ob
ses valeurs je souhaite rappeler très
brièvement
de quoi se plaignent les contestataires
quelle est leur reproche très brièvement
premièrement après le deuxième tour le
bureau politique du parti communiste a
dit c'est un succès pour le parti tout
compte fait alors et disent non c'est un
échec de la gauche donc on si un échec
pour le parti communiste il faut en
chercher les raisons
deuxièmement ils ont dit si la gauche a
perdu a dit le bureau politique c'est la
faute des socialistes et des socialistes
seuls les contestataires disent non la
protection - partager enfin dernier
élément les contestataires 10 depuis
plusieurs mois la ligne du parti et
hésitante et n'est pas claire les
militants ne comprennent pas d'où ce que
vous avez entendu remise en cause une ex
d'une trop grande personnalisation et
demande d'un la réunion d'un congrès
extraordinaire dernière question dans un
cane vous avez parlé de cellules de
fédérations autant qu'on sache à
l'intérieur du bureau politique ça se
passe comment il ya des tendances a
aussi dans les cobistes déteste qu'on
dit ça et pourtant ce serait caricatural
de considérer qu'un mécontentement la
base et qu'on ne retrouve pas au bureau
politique il y a un bureau politique
évidemment le reflète ces tendances là
quelques télégrammes de politique
étrangère maintenant tensions au sein du
parti communiste espagnol là aussi la
section catalan se déclarent contre la
bande en du léninisme proposé par le
comité central qui souhaitait la seule
mention de marxistes ensuite de la
tournée de lénine brejnev en sibérie
s'est arrêté aujourd'hui à 60 kilomètres
de la frontière chinoise
visiblement il s'agit d'une opération
destinée à impressionner les dirigeants
de pékin tchad le français christian
masset son camarade suisse détenu depuis
plus de deux mois se porte bien et ne
sont pas en danger a déclaré aujourd'hui
un porte parole du gouvernement
helvétique à berne
et puis rome vaste opération policière
pour essayer de retrouver les ravisseurs
de monsieur aldo moro 130 personnes ont
été interpellées et la police a procédé
à 48 arrestations dans les milieux
d'extrême rouge
il y à quelques minutes j'apprenais que
monsieur moreau avait envoyé une
nouvelle lettre cette fois ci au
secrétaire général de la démocratie
chrétienne pour demander l'ouverture de
négociations avec libre et al les
brigades rouges
enfin à luxembourg début des
négociations sur les prix agricoles
femmes ont
marathon avicole le reportage de jean
louis calmejane dans notre dernier
journal la marée noire maintenant le
plan polmar terre levée en
ille-et-vilaine et dans le département
de la manche le danger est moins précis
dans cette région la pollution n'a
toujours pas déplacé bréhat dans le
finistère les côtes du nord les équipes
de volontaires et de militaires ont
maintenant atteint leur plein rendement
s'agit de tout faire pour sauver la
saison d'été et les agents immobiliers
de ces deux départements qui se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à trégastel répète
aux vacanciers de ne pas se décommander
leur demande de venir sur ses côtes qui
devrait donc être nettoyée pour le mois
de juin aso mitterrand qui était
aujourd'hui à brest a critiqué le manque
d'autorité internationale de la france
ainsi que l'inexistence et
l'inefficacité du plan polmar le
gouvernement français a dans cette
matière non pas seulement manqué
d'esprit de prévisions baisse aussi
manqué d'autorité internationale je
pense que sur le plan de limay diable il
serait bon de traduire en actes ce qui a
été manquée il y a deux ans il faut
mettre à la disposition des équipes de
nettoyage d'autres moyens que ceux dont
elle dispose j'ajoute que ce qui risque
d'être dangereux c'est que retombe en
quelques semaines
une action qui exigera des mois
c'est en ce sens que ma visite en
bretagne prend un sens elle marque notre
volonté à nous élus au niveau national
mes soucis à vous élus nationaux et
locaux
notre e la mesure d'une persévérance qui
sera nécessaire une fois que les feux de
l'actualité ce seront éloignés de la
bretagne
je crains pour l'avoir vécu en d'autres
circonstances que ceux qui vivent
travaillent et souffre sur cette terre
sur sept mais ne se sente bien isolé
terminons avec la cérémonie des oscars
cette nuit à hollywood c'était la 50e du
nom
encore un beau coup de chapeau au cinéma
français avec l'oscar du meilleur film
étranger pour la vie devant soi de moshe
mizrahi et puis une belle récompense
pour deux acteurs qu'on connaît mal en
france diane keaton la meilleure des
dames et richard dreyfuss le meilleur
des hommes au score sans grande surprise
robes du soir et noeud papillon
l'industrie américaine du cinéma est
plutôt une forêt à hollywood la surprise
est dans la rue devant le palais du
festival de violentes bagarres arbitré
par la police de los angelès oppose
pro-palestiniens et pro israélien
responsable de la bataille de rue
incentive vanessa redgrave oscar du
second rôle féminin pour josiane elle
est anglaise et licences féminines et de
la cause palestinienne
oscar du meilleur film étranger pour la
france madame rosa la vie devant soi de
moshe mizrahi avec simone signoret c'est
le deuxième oscar français consécutif
après la vie en chantant de jean jacques
annaud l'an dernier et la moisson
américaine une belle collection d'oscar
technique pour la guerre des étoiles
meilleur montage meilleurs costumes
meilleure sont meilleurs effets spéciaux
et surtout record absolu en dollars des
recettes de l'histoire du cinéma
wells côté acteurs triangle richard
dreyfuss meilleur rôle masculin pour the
good bye gueule le jeune richard a battu
l'ancien leurs tonnes lucie fabrice
andrivon a charmé de poker objecteurs de
conscience interprète de shakespeare à
la scène mais déjà remarqué dans les
dents de la mer
l'image d'une nouvelle génération tout
comme yann keaton meilleure actrice avec
ses costumes trop large sa démarche
garçons elle est ici dans monsieur good
par son dernier film mais elle a
triomphé pour annie hall l'oeuvre la
plus couronnée à hollywood
son metteur en scène vous dit allen ex
intime de diane keaton n'est pas venu il
n'aime ni la californie ni les
mondanités ni les récompenses voilà les
innovations en seine et marne provoque
toujours des inquiétudes malgré un léger
respect de décrue la situation reste
sérieuse et la météo ne prévoit rien de
bon brouillards et nuages abondant sur
l'ensemble du pays plus au nord sur tout
près de la manche
ailleurs temps variable avec des ondées
orageuses surtout sur les pires patrick
le quoi vous présentera le dernier
journal près les dossiers de l'écran
c'est à dire vers 23h30 il voudra alors
les résultats de nantes nanciers de
strasbourg nantes
en football et il vous souhaite ainsi
que moi d'ailleurs une excellente de
soirée j'ai dit tout à l'heure nantes
nancy c'est nancy nice et puis j'espère
donc avoir le plaisir de vous retrouver
donne un bon soir